it was no quitting you man you guys play
your butt off you fall hard to the very
darn end and I'm proud of you you have
nothing you have nothing to hang your
head down with I'm proud of y'all man
I'm not disappointed whatsoever I know
we could have done much better but I'm
unbelievably proud of each and every one
of you guys you know it was a hard
season for us a group of men coming
together that we never seen before next
year Bally we wi morning for games we
coming different next year for sure
expectations for next year just go out
and ball try to come to highest draft
pick I can try to win some with my team
try to get the national championship try
to get a bowl game just try to get
everything we didn't get this year hey
it's going to be a better year for me
better year for the team if you fans of
us stay with us we got y'all we won't
let y'all down next
year